all right tonight just like we did with
Hillary Clinton's giant web of
corruption we're going to actually show
you which charts just how corrupt
abusively biased and political special
counsel robert muller and his team of
so-called investigators really are this
is on the surface complicated stay with
us tonight we're gonna set the stage we
will explain and break down everything
for you let's start with the head of the
snake that would be the special counsel
Robert Muller Muller's credibility is in
the gutter tonight with these new
discoveries his conflicts of interest is
clear bias the corruption are on full
display Muller is frankly a disgrace to
the American justice system and has put
the country now on the brink of becoming
a banana republic here's why robert
muller former FBI director under bush
and obama was first appointed as a
special counsel to the russia probe by
Deputy Attorney General Rod Rosenstein
Rosenstein longtime federal attorney was
only able to appoint Muller because the
Attorney General Jeff Sessions you
remember recused himself from the Russia
investigation that was a huge mistake by
the way he may want to unruhe cues
himself now you might remember this came
after sessions and Rosenstein encouraged
President Trump to fire then FBI
director James Comey over his
inappropriate actions in the 2016
Clinton email investigation well as it
turns out James Comey guess what he's
very good friends with Robert Muller
after years of working in similar roles
while some have even described the duo
as quote brothers in arms isn't that so
cute now Comey also tweeting tonight he
is meeting with his book publisher I
can't wait for that to come out when's
he gonna start working for fake News CNN
or conspiracy theory TV MSNBC we'll have
more on that later
but back to Muller his conflicts of
interest did not end here while serving
as the FBI director in the Obama
administration Muller stood by and did
nothing while the controversial sale of
uranium was approved by Hillary Clinton
and others in 2010 too that state-owned
Russian energy company now keep in mind
a year and a half before the FBI had
serious Evan
of Russian bribery linked to the Iranian
one sale and a confidential informant
was providing them further proof for six
years of a potentially illicit deal 20%
of America's uranium was at stake we
don't have enough uranium
another important molar conflict it
stems from President Trump remember he
reportedly interviewed Muller to be
commis replacement as the head of the
FBI and ultimately President Trump he
went in another direction he gave the
job to Christopher Bray and finally one
of the biggest examples of Muller's
faulty clouded biased abusively by his
judgment is who he chose to staff the
Russian probe now get this at least
eight of the sixteen lawyers that Muller
appointed to his team donated to
Democrats like Obama and Clinton
including thousands of dollars to these
campaigns
not a single attorney Muller appointed
or hired donated to the Trump campaign
or any other Republican presidential
campaign which brings us to our next
chart where we exposed members of
Muller's team from their clear political
bias one of Mulder's top lieutenants who
some have called a legal pit bull is
none other than Andrew Weissman we'll
have more on him later in this monologue
and show but first it's important to
point out Weissman gave for $1,300 in
political donations to Democrats
including Obama and as you can see we
filled out the chart
all told Muller's corrupt band of
Clinton lovers they've been responsible
for over 50,000 dollars in donations to
Democrats we're really supposed to
believe that they are fair and they're
unbiased in this investigation next up
former top FBI counterintelligence
official Peter struck as we're about to
show you as we told you about last night
his tentacles touch just about
everything now there's more stunning new
information about struck tonight we'll
get to that in a second but first let's
lay the foundation
according to a report this was yesterday
struck is a member of Muller's special
counsel team that signed the document
that officially started the entire
Russian investigation witch-hunt we
learned yesterday this Trump aiding
Clinton loving agent oversaw the FBI
interviews of our former national
security adviser Lou ten
General Michael Flynn where he
supposedly lied Sarah Carter will join
us in a little bit is reporting that
struck personally interrogated Flynn
himself and Fox News also learned that
it was struck that was fired by Muller
over the summer for sending the
anti-trump pro Clinton text messages to
his FBI lawyer girlfriend what we just
discovered tonight that strux girlfriend
lisa page also was on Muller's team
before leaving we didn't know that
yesterday and from there it gets even
more shocking as her own catherine
herridge is reporting struck played a
very key role in the clinton email
server investigation
now this politicized FBI official even
participated in the July 2nd 2016
interview of then former Secretary of
State Hillary Clinton we're conveniently
she was not put under oath now this part
is brand-new tonight struck was also
present at FBI interviews of Clinton's
top aides Huma Abedin Cheryl Mills where
they claim they only knew about the
server after Clinton left the State
Department and it became public
he loves the Clintons and everybody
around them and it turns out emails from
2010 and 11 show that both Abidine and
mills did in fact know about the server
so either they mislead the FBI or
flat-out lied
where are the charges against them and
why were they spared and Lieutenant
General Michael Flynn why was he charged
with lying to the FBI a massive double
standard and it gets worse from there
Fox News has confirmed that struck
changed the language he was the guy in
James commis draft memo exonerating
Hillary Clinton from grossly negligent
behavior to extreme carelessness that's
letting Hillary Clinton off the hook
remember they wrote the exoneration
before the investigation that means the
fix was in gross negligence is part of
the legal standard that would mean
Clinton broke the law they stood up for
her they defended her they protected her
this is shocking and this is why the
Office of Inspector General is now
reviewing Peter Struck's role in the
Clinton email server investigation now
strux involvement extends to other key
areas of this Russian probe keep up with
me here there's a lot of information
like the anti-trump fake news Russia
propaganda dossier that used current and
former Russian government sources to try
and smear then-candidate Trump with
salacious lies and influence the
election and mislead you the American
people and a source is now revealing to
Fox News that deputy FBI director Andrew
McCabe he's the key witness that
Congress wants to talk to about the
anti-trump dossier McCabe was scheduled
to appear before Congress Thursday but
now is saying he's not going to show up
now McCabe is also thought to have been
the key point of contact to the former
British spy Christopher Steele he's the
guy that created the fake news the
anti-trump dossier that was bought and
paid for by Hillary Clinton and the DNC
that Donna Brazile says she was running
and we can't forget according to
multiple reports a political action
committee with ties to key Clinton ally
Virginia Governor Terry McCulloch if
they're like best friends well they gave
five hundred thousand dollars to Andrew
McCabe's wife Jill she was running for
the Virginia State Senate race now
Virginia's Democratic Party also
contributed over 200 grand to jill
McCabe Wow the connections are stunning
and finally house investigators they
believe that struck is the key figure in
the Pfizer surveillance of a trump
associate on the campaign now that makes
a lot of sense given FBI agents
background in counterintelligence and
also tonight and finally tonight there's
Robert Muller's top deputy pay close
attention this particular minion is
known as molars legal pit bull we're
talking about the hard-charging
prosecutor Andrew Weissman he has a long
history of using highly questionable
unethical tactics to get convictions
there's new information tonight and it
highlights Weissman's rampant anti-trump
bias we'll get to that in a second
before we do you've got to understand
who is Andrew Weissman now Fox News
legal analyst Greg Jarrett has done deep
into Weissman's background here is what
he is found back in 2000 during the
massive Enron scandal Weissman was one
of the prosecutors on the task force
that brought a very controversial
obstruction of justice case against the
giant accounting for
Arthur Anderson this is important
Weissman's actions put that company out
of business tens of thousands of people
lost their jobs in 2005 the United
States Supreme Court overturned
Weissman's obstruction of justice
conviction in a unanimous 9-0 nearly
unprecedented ruling but it was too late
he had already inflicted maximum damage
to so many people Arthur Andersen was
not the only victim of Weitzman's
aggressive tactics the conviction of a
business transaction between Enron and
the financial firm Merrill Lynch well
that sent people to jail but guess what
they were innocent that decision was
reversed by the Fifth Circuit US Circuit
Court of Appeals Weissman has also been
accused of intimidating witnesses making
up crimes that don't exist and in one
case withholding evidence that was at
school battery that helped the defendant
and Weissman is also tied to that
corrupt uranium one deal and the Obama
administration cover-up
why did Muller ever appoint this guy he
knew his track record and back then
Weissman was in charge of the do J's
fraud section during the Russian bribery
scheme and his Gregg Jarrett points out
Weissman actually signed the bottom of
the plea agreement from the Russian
businessman involved in that case now
here's the new explosive information we
have tonight in an email released after
a FOIA request by Judicial Watch
Weissman the guy I'm telling you about
he told the former acting Attorney
General Sally Yates and Obama appointee
he was proud of her what was he so proud
of
Yates denied a direct order from the
president
her boss refused to defend the legal
constitutional travel ban back in
January
Wiseman's email reads quote I am so
proud I am in awe thank you so much all
my deepest respects pretty unbelievable
shows where his political biases also
tonight your mainstream media they're
corrupt they continue to spread fake
news all in an attempt to destroy and
damage this president day-in day-out
hour after hour minute after
minute the latest example involves
reports that a special counsel as he
issued a subpoena to deutsche bank for
information about bank accounts that
were held by President Trump and his
family well tonight we learn it's fake
news president Trump's lawyer Jay
Sekulow he shot down this erroneous
reporting with the statement the reads
quote we have confirmed that the news
reports that the Special Counsel has
subpoenaed financial records relating to
the president are false no subpoena has
been issued or received we have
confirmed this with the bank and other
sources this is just another reason you
the American people should never trust
this destroy Trump corrupt media and
finally tonight Robert Robert Muller's
political witch-hunt comes at a massive
cost to all of us the American taxpayers
now from may to the end of September
alone Muller has spent nearly 7 million
of your dollars on his corrupt his
crooked investigation that has now
turned into this political fishing
expedition remember this all started as
a probe into possible Trump Russia
collusion there's been zero evidence so
far none zero it's been almost a year
that this ever happened and the media
Russia Russia Russia
so now Muller and his political lackeys
they're trying to dig up any kind of
potential wrongdoing to justify their
existence this is a massive waste of
money and you the American people are
paying for all of this which is an
attempted political takedown of your
duly elected president it is a direct
threat tonight to the rule of law to our
Constitution and tonight this all now
begins to end